bonjour monsieur kalfayan merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
l'accord de cessez le feu est perçu
comme une véritable trahison par
l'opposition un accord au douloureux
selon les mots du premier ministre nikol
pashinian qu'il ya donc à signer le
texte
est ce que l'on se dirige actuellement
vers une crise politique en arménie
la crise politique en tout cas c'est la
crise de confiance entre la population
et le premier ministre a tout simplement
on lui reproche le fait d'avoir signé un
tel document qui est un document qui est
à mi chemin entre le cessez le feu et un
traité de paix et qu'ils n'avaient
d'ailleurs pas le droit de signer en
tout cas il n'avait pas le droit
d'engager l'arménie d'état arménien tout
seul
puisqu'en fait il le pouvoir de ratifier
un traité selon la constitution
arménienne appartient au parlement à
l'assemblée nationale arménienne est
donc aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec un
traité qui était vaste at her pour
l'avenir de du karabagh mais peut-être
même pour l'avenir de l'arménie
parce que il n'ya pas que des clauses
qui concerne à cesser le feu
il y à des clauses qui vont engager en
fait déjà les futurs délimitation
territoriale du karabagh certainement
et il ya même une perte de souveraineté
sur certaines parties du territoire
arménien donc donc c'est pas seulement
l'opposition qui est en colère c'est
l'ensemble de la population parce
qu'elle a est là elle comprend bien que
c'est joué peut-être l'avenir de
la nation arménienne dans cette région
alors la grande perdante ancien si on
peut résumer c'est bien évidemment
l'arménie puisque elle doit comme vous
venez de dire rendre certains
territoires qu'elle avait pris à
l'azerbaïdjan mais surtout elle perd le
contrôle militaire du haut karabagh
l'azerbaïdjan elle a été soutenue très
fortement par par la turquie on sait que
cet accord a été signé
grâce à grâce à la russie 1 sous l'égide
de la russie
les troupes russes d'ailleurs sont
désormais à présent sur place au final
qui sort gagnant c'est la russie et la
turquie
écoutez pour pour l'instant ce n'est pas
bon pour l'instant si on regarde les
choses comme elles sont c'est surtout la
russie parce que c'est elle qui va
finalement être là le gendarme
entre larmes et des arbitres gens même
si la dure qui prétend qu'elle serait
impliqué dans le maitien le maintien du
cessez le feu
sur la ligne de front entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan
maintenant il faudrait regarder à plus
long terme parce que d'abord cela crée
des oppositions à l'intérieur même des
pays
et deuxièmement il n'est pas certain que
les états unis et dit leur dernier mot
dans cette affaire
ils ont été absents du processus
la france a été également absent du
processus parce qu'en fait en procédant
de cette manière là réussi à
complètement fait exploser en vol
le format du groupe de minsk dans lequel
se trouvait donc comme médiateur russie
france etats unis
c'était un format qui a été reconnue par
l'ensemble des organisations
intergouvernementales dans le monde tous
les pays
renvoyait donc la négociation sur ce
groupe sur ce format là or la russie
vient de tout simplement de violer ce
format est donc là aussi un autre sujet
juridique
est-ce que cet accord n'en n'a pas en
quelque sorte violet est finalement un
droit international qui avaient été
imposées par les nations unies par
l'ouest et par l'union européenne pour
donc aboutir à une solution finale mais
mais justement cet accord n'a t-il pas
aussi montré en fait on va dire la
faiblesse de la diplomatie européenne
l'échec même du groupe de minsk puisque
depuis des années il ya des négociations
pour faire appliquer en fait c'est le
feu entre les deux parties alors le
cessez le feu
sur le papier existait depuis 1994
mais il ya toujours eu les escarmouches
sur la ligne de front bon là ce qui
s'est passé ces derniers temps c'est
d'abord des provocations
donc inutile de part et d'autre payant
de la part de l'exécutif arménien et la
part de l'exécutif azerbaïdjanais qui
ont conduit donc à une exaspération et
donc à la reprise des hostilités pour le
deuxième facteur qui a précipité donc
cette guerre est donc la défaite
inéluctable de l'arménie c'est c'est
la turquie qui a dit bon ça suffit
maintenant il faut remettre les choses
en place
donc c'est la turquie qui en fait a
déclenché cette guerre ils ont obtenu
satisfaction
l'arménie est effectivement en l'état
des choses
la grande perdante parce que on ne voit
pas très bien comment finalement le
karabagh arméniens ne peut pas enfin une
de plus à disparaître
enfin il va disparaître dans ces
conditions là et c'est l'arménie qui se
sent fragilisé sur ses frontières même
donc le seule lueur d'espoir c'est c'est
en tout cas pour dans la vie politique
arménienne c'est c'est d'un valider cet
accord parce que c'est cet accord n'a
aucune valeur juridique selon la
constitution arménienne
tant que le parlement ne l'a pas ratifié
merci beaucoup monsieur philippe
kalfayan d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes juriste et
chercheur associé en droit international
public et ancien secrétaire général de
la fédération internationale des droits
humains